[Applauso]
Io vi parlerò di agricoltura e
innovazione un binomio che è stato alla
base del mio impegno imprenditoriale In
questa terra e il legame Con
l'agricoltura è dovuto anche al fatto
che nascono in un territorio ricco di
storia in cui l'agricoltura è stata
dalla Magna Grecia in poi
il settore trainante dell'Economia e
infatti
l'economia delle polis greche si basava
proprio sull'agricoltura
io ritengo che
questo settore Non a caso detto settore
primario sia importante non solo per la
produzione di beni ma anche per il ruolo
che svolge per la salvaguardia
dell'ambiente e del pianeta
la svolta in questo territorio avviene
Negli anni cinquanta con la riforma
agraria passiamo da una palude
inospitale
alla a un processo che diverso da quello
che
hanno altri posti altri luoghi in Italia
negli anni sessanta
l'industrializzazione
interessa molte regioni italiane la
Puglia Ma qui avviene un fatto nuovo e
l'agricoltura che cambia il destino di
questa terra e di tante persone che
dalle aree interne si trasferiscono qui
nel Metapontino dove vengono assegnati
dei poteri per permettere alla famiglia
dell'agricoltore
dell'Artigiano del commerciante del
calzolaio di poter alimentare e
soddisfare le esigenze della famiglia
in pochi anni questo territorio cambia
alle coltivazioni
cerealicole che erano tipiche del
periodo
del secondo dopoguerra si sostituiscono
impianti specializzati di agrumi di
pesche di Albicocco cambia il volto di
questa regione cambia il volto di
quest'area cambia il destino di molti di
noi cambia il destino dei miei genitori
che si trasferiscono qui da un paese
limitrofo per avere questo pezzo di
terra ed iniziare
un'avventura sarà stata una vertigine
per i nostri genitori trasferirsi dai
luoghi
interni di questa regione in un
territorio che fino a poco a pochi anni
prima era considerata un terreno un
ambiente inospitale Infatti si diceva
Policoro che ci vacci muore eppure in
pochi anni avviene un miracolo una
trasforma zione di questo territorio
si passa
dall'autoconsumo della famiglia
contadina al mercato perché le nuove
produzioni vengono destinate al mercato
e ovviamente
cambia il ruolo dell'agricoltore che non
deve soddisfare più le esigenze della
famiglia ma deve approcciare al mercato
e il mercato ha delle regole e
concorrenziale chiede dei prodotti
particolari e quindi l'agricoltura deve
organizzarsi deve strutturare la propria
azienda deve organizzare mezzi della
produzione la logistica deve assumere
manodopera Quindi
Cambia il
il volto del
territorio e da agricoltore
si passa
a imprenditore e un salto un salto molto
difficile molto difficile che non tutti
riescono a effettuare perché le sfide
sono tante le incognite sono tante il
mercato è complesso e allora chi riesce
a superare questo questo salto lo supera
anche chi è un po' incosciente ma ha una
grande propensione al rischio lo supera
Chi ha idee visione e competenza perché
mi sono convinta che l'imprenditori non
si nasce Si diventa perché se fosse vero
che
abbiamo un gene dell'imprenditorialità
che trasferiamo ai nostri figli
sicuramente questa zona non avrebbe
conosciuto tanti imprenditori di grande
livello che sono orgoglio della nostra
regione
il vero salto di qualità del meteo
pontino è sicuramente
l'introduzione di una coltivazione che
ci porterà ad essere conosciuti a
livello europeo come
una
comprensorio un distretto di qualità di
frutta di altissima qualità
e la fragola è un frutto che viene dalla
California
un paese lontanissimo e che trova in
questo territorio le condizioni
climatiche
ideali per la sua coltivazione
accanto alle fragole poi Inseriamo i
lamponi inseriamo le more
Ma cosa succede con la produzione della
fragola ci troviamo di fronte un
prodotto nuovo abbiamo bisogno di
know-how abbiamo bisogno di adattare le
cultivar provenienti da così lontano da
oltreoceano alle nostre condizioni alle
nostre esigenze e guardate il primo
problema che ci poniamo è quello di
individuare
delle varietà che siano più performanti
per le nostre esigenze e per il nostro
mercato
è il primo problema che abbiamo è quello
di avere delle cultivar che producevano
in un periodo limitato 60 giorni
in 60 giorni con un investimento
notevole era difficile fare reddito
perché avevamo un surplus produttivo
vi avevamo al mercato molto prodotto
Sapete bene se c'è un eccesso di offerta
il prezzo crolla e quindi non avevamo
degli ottimi risultati e allora il
problema era quello di trovare una
soluzione
a questo problema allungare il più
possibile il periodo di raccolta e
questo era possibile soltanto
introducendo nuove tipologie di piante e
quindi
il primo problema che ci siamo posti e
di andare a trovare delle soluzioni
in tutto il mondo
e questo mi ha portato a conoscere dei
gruppi a livello internazionale e un
gruppo di questi aveva il brevettato
delle varietà e introdotto una tipologia
di pianta che consentiva di produrre per
sei mesi la svolta la svolta per il
Metapontino che comincia a produrre
questa nuova pianta questa nuova pianta
che ci permetteva di rimanere sul
mercato 6 mesi di fedelizzare i nostri
clienti sul mercato e quindi il boom Le
superfici aumentano l'offerta
scalare arriva sul mercato in sei mesi
quindi conquistiamo il mercato italiano
esportiamo all'estero la Basilicata
diventa la prima regione italiana per
superfici coltivate a Fragola ma non
solo fragole
quantitativamente interessanti ma
fragole di altissima qualità
ma ci rendemmo subito conto che
il consumatore finale non riusciva a
distinguere una fragola dall'altra messe
in un cestino anonimo e portata sul
mercato il consumatore era
era impossibile riconoscere una fragola
dall'altra e Sfido chiunque a
riconoscere se una fragola è buona o
Quali sono le caratteristiche migliori
tra uno e l'altra E allora con un gruppo
di produttori locali
abbiamo costituito un consorzio e
abbiamo con le parole con la
comunicazione
fatto conoscere le caratteristiche della
nostra fragola dove Nasceva come veniva
prodotta chi c'era dietro quel cestino
di fragola e poi i mezzi di
comunicazione il QR Code ci ha permesso
di dire al consumatore Questo è il
prodotto che noi facciamo dietro questo
prodotto c'è un produttore c'è una
famiglia di produttori ci sono tecniche
culturali innovative e quindi anche
sfatare il mito delle Fragole piene di
pesticidi eccetera eccetera e quindi
riuscimmo in questo modo a dare valore
alla nostra produzione
sembrerebbe una storia lieto fine ma
oggi siamo di fronte a dei cambiamenti
epocali per l'agricoltura Siamo di
fronte ai cambiamenti climatici alle
esigenze mutevoli del mercato i
consumatori sono cambiati i consumatori
vogliono prodotti più sostenibili
vogliono novità
vogliono produzione più salubri
e quindi le sfide che abbiamo davanti
sono delle sfide importanti e ritornando
sul concetto dell'Agricoltura che
salverà il mondo
noi nel 2050 cioè domani avremo una
popolazione che sfiora i 10 miliardi di
abitanti sulla terra abbiamo la
necessità di produrre il 60 per cento in
più di quello che stiamo producendo
attualmente ma soprattutto abbiamo
l'esigenza di non
utilizzare
suolo e acqua che sono due elementi
fondamentali per l'agricoltura e per il
pianeta che non sono riproducibili
E allora la ricerca
in questo momento sono impegnato in un
processo in un progetto di ricerca qui a
Policoro perché la ricerca perché la
ricerca Oggi più che mai è fondamentale
per poter permettere all'agricoltura di
continuare a produrre
utilizzando quelle risorse che non sono
riproducibili in modo oculato la ricerca
ci dà la possibilità di avere delle
piante resilienti
delle piante che possono essere
coltivate utilizzando sempre meno
prodotti chimici
utilizzando prodotti naturali gli
insetti che mangiano gli altri insetti e
quindi di avere delle produzioni
sostenibili sprecare meno acqua perché
Con l'agricoltura moderna l'agricoltura
4.0 Noi abbiamo la possibilità di
comprendere quanta acqua ha bisogno una
piantina e quindi non sprecarla
Vi è mai capitato di vedere l'acqua che
inonda il campo in onda il frutteto bene
È una
un'immagine che dobbiamo dimenticare
perché l'acqua è un bene prezioso non
riproducibile E noi come imprenditori
abbiamo la necessità di individuare
strumenti che le nuove tecnologie ci
consentono per ridurre al minimo il loro
spreco quindi l'agricoltura 4.0 e un
agricoltura che guarda al futuro del
pianeta
garantendo sostenibilità ambientale
economica e sociale per la salvaguardia
dell'umanità
volendo chiudere con una fase di Darwin
il quale diceva nella giungla non vince
il più forte o il più intelligente ma
colui il quale sa abituarsi ai
cambiamenti Grazie
[Applauso]